[Music]
he's played second fiddle to iron man
second fiddle to iron man supporting
cast and second fiddle to iron man's
astrologer but this time tom holland
swings into uncharted territory playing
third fiddle
to spider-man
spider-man no way home
the worst kept secret in nerdum is out
all the live-action spider-men are back
except for the two from the 70s
[Music]
they've taken a break from either
starring in oscar-nominated movies or
narrating the boss baby in a film that
pleases everyone from millennials who
look as old as toby did in spider-man 1
to younger revisionists who insist
everyone secretly loved the andrew
garfield movies
with so many in-jokes memes and
references you know
i'm something of a scientist myself
you'll swear you've been in a coma since
2014. you are amazing no i kind of
needed to hear that thank you huh
doesn't really sound too bad actually i
want to forget you're so soft poop i've
been a bad kitty
spider-man's identity has been revealed
and peter's only solution is to
brainwash everyone so they forget all
the horrible things he's done tony would
be so proud
thrill as he teams up with a sorcerer
supreme to wave his hands around and say
multiverse until the sony films pop out
pulling in all the characters you loved
some of the characters you forgot about
and none of the characters sony would
like you to forget about in this
potentially cosmic thread that sounds
like a job for doctor strange but this
time he's been replaced with someone
more like dr oz
i'm sorry sir
you should not be able to do that i've
been dangling over the grand canyon for
12. i know i know i know if he turns out
to be a scroll i'm gonna be so pissed
last please with myself for calling it
while spider-man is busy fiddling with
two different magic boxes discovering
the scientific cure for evil and other
relatable teenage stuff like dating
zendaya or being too famous for college
you'll catch up with old pals like flash
thompson a bully who's taken so many l's
he had to green screen himself into a
party the faculty of midtown high who
really deserve their own disney plus
series please mysterio was right stop we
don't that's all a sad happy i could
have been more funny hang out again
how do you think and ant-may who's ready
to graduate from being a female sex
object to being a female sex object
killed off to motivate the male hero
oh don't feel too bad pete everyone you
love has to die no matter what universe
you're in my uncle ben was killed it was
my fault i lost gwen i am
she was my mj
why are you crying this is supposed to
be inspirational
watch marvel pull off a sinister six
minus one like it was no big deal
featuring willem defoe's iconic green
goblin one of the best comic book movie
performances ever norman's on sabbatical
honey alfred molina's well-earned
victory lap as doc ock when he's not
being roasted by zoomers dr otto
octavius
wait no seriously what's your actual
name jamie foxx's electro who improves
on his debut by changing every single
thing about it what happened to you did
you get a makeover sandman's
there and lizard who they keep in a
truck to hide the fact that he looked
better 10 years ago even reptile in the
new mortal kombat looked better even
reptile in the old mortal kombat looked
better but spidey won't give up on
curing all these bad boys of their
impure thoughts in fact he'll dose them
with hot liquid therapy then portal them
back to the lives they've already ruined
thanks spider-man norman osborne may
have lost his son company and reputation
but now he'll be able to feel crippling
regret over it
so get ready to cheer when you see it in
theaters
[Applause]
because those moments are just awkward
to watch by yourself at home
hello
and what's still an amazing two and a
half hour brain vacation that's the
cinematic equivalent of all your exes
coming together to reminisce on all the
good times you had i love you guys and
not the time they made you well you know
watch amazing spider-man 2
starring
peter parker picked a pack of partners
whip whip boom
the spider house rules
zen and the art of multiversal
maintenance ant-man
the sorcerer's apprentice
the assistant to the regional sorcerer
if i were a fix man
the green golem project power i don't
like sand
welcome back connors alex jones jameson
netflix and billable hours
and say the line say it with great power
there must also come great
responsibility yay
the adventures of pete and pete and pete
don't let mit be dumb like me mit is
dumb well you're the vice chancellor and
you can't figure out a child-proof lock
so
maybe door's locked
hey screen junkies we've all got our
personal favorites but which version of
spider-man has actually saved the most
civilians who's been bullied the most
who's upside down made out more than
once we put these three spider-man to
the test to find out which spider reigns
supreme in our latest episode of by the
numbers click the thumbnail on the right
to see who wins
every triangle is a love triangle when
you love triangles
if you want to be my lover you gotta get
with my friends
nutella is angelic pew
this program was made possible by
contributions to your pbs station from
viewers like you thank you